hey everyone Pierre Brown here with the
game spot news update today at quakecon
it's software announced the next sequel
to doom titled doom like the star trek
movie and tomb raider game the new doom
is dropping the sequel number and going
back to the beginning we've gotten
teasers of the game before but at this
year's quakecon conference its software
showed off the new game to the attendees
the demonstration at quakecon took place
on Mars outside of an aerospace
corporation building in it the player
used a lot of brutal combat melee moves
and even ripped the arm off of a guard
to get through a biometric sensor it is
also designing a variety of unique and
powerful weapons and enemies and you'll
be able to carry around a large arsenal
of weapons rather than just two guns at
a time there will be a beta for xbox one
playstation 4 MPC which you could
guarantee access to by pre-ordering
Wolfenstein the new order no release
details have been announced yet but we
know it runs on it text 6 at 1080p and
what you know 60 frames per second are
you pumped for the new doom these guys
are dude it was bad I really wish I knew
what the hell those guys were looking at
anyway for more Duke news stay tuned to
gamespot com